FEMALE SPEAKER: Hello everyone
and thank you for coming.
I'm excited to introduce Jeanne
Sauvage of "Gluten-Free Baking
for the Holidays."
And thank you Jeanne for coming.
JEANNE SAUVAGE: So, thank
you very much for having me.
I'm honored to be here.
Let me get a sense of who here
is gluten free themselves.
OK it looks like
a good majority.
And how many people
are here just
because either their friends
and family are gluten free,
or they're just
interested in the topic?
OK.
Great, thank you for coming.
So I wrote a book
on-- or a cookbook--
on gluten-free baking.
Specifically, gluten free
baking for the holidays.
And I call my journey to getting
to this point of the road
to deliciousness.
So because one of
my goals with gluten
free baking is to make things
that taste and feel good.
There's no point in baking
if it's gross, really.
So I wanted to give you
a little taste of why
wrote a book about
gluten free baking.
How I got here.
And so to give you a
little bit of my history
I was diagnosed as
gluten intolerant
after the birth of
my daughter in 2000.
And apparently
that's very common.
Autoimmune disorders are often
triggered by a body trauma.
And a body trauma can be
something like pregnancy,
childbirth, a very bad
cold, a car accident.
And so the more I
talked to people
who are gluten
intolerant, the more
I realized that
this trigger point
is very common with
a lot of people.
Now with me, I was completely
shocked by the entire thing.
I had no idea that
this was possible.
But the more I thought
about it, the more
I realized that my funny
tummy my whole life
made a lot of sense actually.
And so I'm one of those people
that my entire life, even
before my diagnosis, I always
felt bad when I ate something.
So I had stomach ache, diarrhea,
bloating, the whole nine yards.
And this happens
every time I ate.
And every time I went to a
doctor they would just say,
oh well I guess you just
have a funny stomach
so just be careful with it.
And that really
wasn't that helpful.
And also I spent a whole lot
of my life just feeling bad,
which isn't great.
Does this story sound
familiar to anybody?
OK so this is
actually something.
There is some
statistic out there
that once you start on the
road to trying to figure out
what's wrong with your system
when you're reacting to gluten
it's something like
12 years from starting
the search for the reason
to the actual diagnosis.
And I think the reason for
this is a lot of doctors
up until now have been trained
that gluten intolerance is
so rare that there's no
point in even looking for it.
It's so rare it doesn't exist.
So they didn't even
think of it as an option.
So my whole life I've never
had a doctor talk about gluten.
I don't even think
I knew what gluten
was until I was diagnosed.
So my first question
of my doctor,
and it may be your
first question as well,
is what is gluten?
Because they kind
of say, oh, hey,
you can't eat gluten, bye bye.
And I thought, OK but I
don't know what that is
and you need to
help me with this.
So after my diagnosis
I realized I
had to know what
gluten was and I also
had to know where it
resided in our food system.
So I wanted to tell you a
little bit about what gluten is.
You may or may not know this.
Gluten is a protein--
actually it's
a combination of
two proteins that
is found-- the two proteins
are gliadin and glutenin.
And these two together make
up the thing we call gluten.
They are found in all
forms of wheat and that
includes spelt, kamut, farro,
durum, emmer, and einkorn.
So I don't know if you
guys have experience
what I've experienced
but I often go places
and they say oh here's a
gluten free thing it's spelt.
And I have to say, no
that's a form of wheat.
So you have to be really careful
about the lack of knowledge
on the part of
the food industry.
It's also found in rye
and it's found in barley.
And then it's also
found in something
called triticale, which is a
combination of rye and wheat.
There's a lot of
question about oats,
and if you haven't been gluten
free for any amount of time
you know about the
concept that you
need to eat gluten free oats.
And oats themselves can
be problematic for people
who can't tolerate gluten.
So there's a
prolamin in oats that
mimics the prolamin
in gluten, which
is called gliadin, the prolamin
in oats is called avenin.
And avenin is
something that people
who are gluten intolerance
often are intolerant to as well.
So if you don't tolerate
gluten, there is a good chance
that you actually don't
tolerate avenin or oats.
If you do tolerate oats, if
you're a gluten free person
you need to make sure that
you buy gluten free oats.
As you may know, oats are often
processed and grown with wheat
so you need to make
sure that you don't
get the cross contaminated oats.
OK, so another question
I get a lot is,
what are the forms of gluten
intolerance, sensitivity,
allergy, there are
all sorts of words
that are floating
around out there.
The main thing that people
seem to know about is celiac.
Celiac is an autoimmune
disorder and it
is caused by-- what happens
is your body-- if you're
prone to it, your body
will attack itself
once you eat gluten.
How many people here are
actually diagnosed celiac?
OK so we have a few folks.
There's also a non-celiac
gluten intolerance.
This is where you're not
celiac but you're still
reacting to gluten.
This category
encompasses a few things
because they're not entirely
clear what the mechanism is.
So if you're not celiac
but you react to gluten
they call it non-celiac gluten
intolerance or sensitivity.
Different doctors call
it different things.
There's not a whole lot of
information out there on this
but it's kind of
just the category
that they lump people into if
you're not actually celiac.
And what non-celiac
gluten intolerance
is, is you are not
autoimmune to gluten,
you're just reacting to it.
There's also a thing
called wheat allergy,
which is a little bit different.
It is when your body mounts a
histamine reaction in to wheat.
And you can actually go into
anaphylaxis if you eat wheat.
It can range from mild to
very strong of a reaction.
Like I said, you can
go into anaphylaxis
and you can die if you have
a really strong allergy.
There is no such thing really
is a gluten allergy they don't
think, but there is
the wheat allergy.
So that's something
to keep in mind.
So I just wanted to
give you a sense of who
reacts to gluten in
the United States.
So you probably have heard the
1 in 133 people in the United
States they think have
celiac, which is about 1%
of the population, and that's
about 3 million people.
Now celiac is a genetically
predetermined disease.
So you need to have
the genes for celiac
in order to develop celiac.
And they think about
30% of the population,
or 94 million people in the
US, have the genes for celiac.
Which is kind of intense.
And you don't necessarily
develop celiac
if you have the gene.
That's the strange thing.
It needs to be
triggered on some level.
So since I am celiac, we test
our daughter, who is now 13,
we test her every few years
for the gliadin antibodies
just to make sure she
hasn't been triggered
and is now full blown celiac.
Because we don't know if
you've got the gene or not,
but there's a good
chance you did
Then there's another
5% of people,
which is 18+ million people
who have the gluten intolerance
that's non-celiac.
And they think it's
way more than that.
They think this is a very
conservative estimate.
And then there's a 0.5%, which
is about 1.5 million people
in the US, that a wheat allergy.
So that just gives you
a sense of the amount
of people that are out
there reacting to gluten.
And it's a lot.
They think these numbers
are very conservative
and that we will see
more and more and more
people that are statistically
diagnosed with these things.
So when I was first
diagnosed, I went
through a pretty huge
mourning process.
I imagine this is pretty
familiar to folks in this room.
I ate gluten all the time
before I was diagnosed.
I had toast and
cereal for breakfast,
I had sandwiches for lunch,
I had pasta for dinner.
I had scones and cookies and
treats throughout the day.
And all of a sudden I was told
you can eat any of those things
and I was just devastated.
And I had a new baby
so I didn't quite
know what to do because
I was used to just making
a quick sandwich
and all our friends
were dropping off meals for us.
And of course all
those meals had gluten
and the hospital
even sent us home
with a meal which was
lasagna and I couldn't that.
So it was kind of
a disaster for me.
And I've talked to a lot of
people who feel the same way.
It's just very hard to get
diagnosed with such a huge food
allergy or
intolerance, especially
if it's something that is part
of your diet all the time.
And this is very common.
Most people are diagnosed with
the food intolerance or allergy
to something that
they eat a lot.
That's how the
body works, it gets
triggered by
constant repetition.
So one thing that
happened to me is
I didn't know how to eat
so I just stopped eating.
So I lost all my
pregnancy weight
in about three weeks, which
is kind of an intense thing.
And then you've got
a baby and it just
was in a very fun situation
for me or my husband.
He didn't know
what was happening
because he had a wife
is sick all the time
and we had a new
baby to deal with.
And so I just went
into mourning.
I just thought well
every good again
and that's just the
way it is and I'm just
going to have to deal with it.
And that actually wasn't
all that satisfying
but that's what I did
for a little while.
Even worse was it that
I had to stop baking,
or I felt like I
had to stop baking.
I'm someone who's
a lifelong baker.
I baked from the
time I was tiny and I
could climb up onto a stool and
get onto the kitchen counter
and access the
cupboards in order
to get the ingredients to bake.
I mean literally I baked
throughout childhood,
I baked throughout college, I
baked throughout grad school.
I also baked as an adult.
And I realized
through this diagnosis
actually that baking is kind
of the through line to my life.
It's my passion, it's my
joy, it's my stress reliever.
And so the concept that
I couldn't bake anymore
was even worse than not being
able to eat gluten anymore.
And I thought I
couldn't bake anymore.
I realized later that I
could but in the beginning
it just felt horrible.
So you go through
a mourning period
where you just feel
like gluten has died
and you can never
talk to it again.
And then you have to pick
yourself up by the bootstraps
eventually and
relearn how to eat.
And I had to relearn
also how to bake
and then you get on with life.
And I know in several people who
tend to get stuck in the fact
that they can't eat
the thing anymore.
And I just realized for me that
wasn't that helpful because it
just made me feel bad all
the time, emotionally bad.
So I just thought you know what?
I'm going to figure
out how to eat again
and also how to bake again.
And that actually has
turned into something
that's very satisfying for me.
So one thing, gluten
as you may know,
comes from the
Latin word for glue.
And that's a really good
description of gluten
because when all else fails
gluten is very sticky.
Now gluten performs a lot
of functions in baking.
In fact, modern baking is based
on how to manipulate gluten
to do what you want it to do.
So you take gluten away you have
a really tough time actually
baking anything.
So one thing I had to do
was learn what gluten did.
And what it turns out gluten
performs several functions
in baking.
It's a binder, it holds things
together, hence the glue name.
And a lot of gluten
free things are
crumbly because they don't
have the appropriate binder.
It's a structure builder.
And what I mean
by that is gluten
serves as like the
tent pole structure
that the starches adhere to
that create a covering that then
the leaveners can work on
to raise the big thing.
So if you don't have gluten,
or a replacer for gluten,
you now have a very flat thing.
And I don't know
about you but I have
run into a zillion gluten
free baked things, like scones
and muffins, that are
kind of hockey pucks.
They're very dense,
they're very heavy,
and they're very crumbly.
And that is due to the binding
and then the structure building
being not there.
The other thing that gluten
does is it's elastic.
So it allows you
to manipulate it.
So when you make a
loaf of artisan bread,
you can form it
on a cookie sheet
and it'll keep it-- you can
stretch it to its shape,
but then you can let it stay
there and it'll keep its shape.
Without gluten things
don't keep their shape.
First of all, stretching
it doesn't really
factor into it because you're
just basically spreading it
around.
And then it just blobs out.
So I don't know
if anyone's tried
to make a bread with
the gluten free dough,
but it's very difficult.
You need a structure like a
loaf pan in order to do that.
Then gluten also is
a moisture retainer.
If helps things retain moisture.
This is why a lot of gluten
free things are very dry.
I don't know if
you've experienced
that but a lot of gluten
free things are dry.
Like again I just
think of hockey pucks,
they're flat and
dry and crumbly.
And it's because there's no
moisture retainer in there,
which is what gluten does.
And then gluten also
extends the shelf life,
so that's related to the
moisture retaining properties.
So when you bake gluten free
you need to find something that
serves all of these functions,
that does all of these things,
and this is the challenge
for gluten free baking.
So in gluten free
baking, we have
to choose what I call
a gluten replacer.
And a gluten
replacer is the thing
that hopefully does all of
those things I talked about.
There are several that
people use nowadays.
There's a thing
called xanthan gum.
There's guar gum.
There's also seeds, ground
seeds, psyllium, flax, chia,
there's pectin, and
there's also gelatin.
There's a lot of controversy
in the gluten free baking world
about which one you should use,
and which one's easier to use,
and which one works the best.
And my experience has shown
me that xanthan gum actually
performs most of the
functions pretty well.
The one function that it
doesn't perform that well,
and but none of them really
do, is in the elasticity part.
It's still hard to
get things that--
to mold things without
them being dry.
And that's something
I'm still working on.
But what all of
these things are,
they fall into a class of
things called hydrocolloids.
And what that means is
they're moisture retainers.
So they can retain hundreds
of times their own weight
in water, which is interesting.
And so each one of these
things you can use in a gluten
free baking product to serve
as the gluten replacer.
And what I mean is you
mix this with the flours
and now you've got a thing
that will mimic gluten,
a gluten flour.
Now in terms of
choosing flours I
thought initially that
all I needed to do
was choose a flour,
add some xanthan gum,
and I'd be good to go.
That would be easy.
And it turns that it's
not that straightforward.
It turns out there's no
one gluten free flour that
behaves like wheat flour, which
is what I wanted to mimic.
So I had to ask some
questions of myself,
and I think all
baker's need to ask
these questions of themselves,
which is what kind of baking
do you want to do?
Do you want to do
whole grain baking?
Do you wanna do
grain free baking?
Do want to do paleo,
which is grain free, sugar
free, sometimes dairy free.
Do you want to do healthy
baking, whatever that means?
Or you want to
experiment with flours?
Do you think the
flours tastes good
and you want to experiment
with different things.
I came down to--
what I wanted to do
was create items that
were indistinguishable
from their wheat counterparts.
And this I think is
what distinguishes me
from a lot of gluten free bakers
in that I work on making things
that everyone is going to want
to eat, gluten free and gluten
full, because they taste
so good and they're
indistinguishable from the
things that they normally get.
So again I thought OK,
I figured this out,
now I need to figure
out how to do the flours
and it turns out with
gluten free baking you
need to mix flours.
No one flour will really
do what you need it to do.
And so you need to
mix flours in order
to mimic the
performance of wheat.
And what I did was I chose a
flour mix that I thought that I
liked and spent several years
tweaking it to perform the way
I wanted it to perform.
So what I did was I
looked at the things
that I wanted it to do.
So first of all I found that
all purpose wheat flour consists
of 80 percent starches and 20
percent gums and protein, which
is kind of a weird combo.
Wheat flour does
have gums in it.
And so I wanted to
mimic that chemistry,
I wanted it to taste
good, so I didn't
want it to taste like bean.
I don't know about you
guys, but a lot of people
use bean flour and that has a
very strong taste that I didn't
want to put into my baked goods.
I wanted it to have
a good mouth feel,
I wanted it to be allergen free,
so the mix that I came up with
doesn't have any of
the common allergies.
That doesn't have soy,
corn, night shades,
which are all-- nuts.
And these are all things that
people in my world reacted to
and I wanted to be
sure to have a mix that
didn't exclude other
people in my life.
And then again I wanted
things to be easy to obtain.
If it was an esoteric
flour that you could only
get from a yak in Kathmandu,
it wasn't helpful for anybody.
So I came up with,
ta-da, Jeanne's gluten
free all purpose flour.
And the recipe for this is
in my book, it's on my site.
And you can make yourself, I
don't sell it as a product.
But what it has in it is brown
rice flour, white rice flour,
sweet rice flour, tapioca
flour, and xanthan gum.
And these are the things--
what I did is I mix this up
and then I use it cup
for cup in my baking.
And I found this to
be pretty satisfying.
So people ask me about
recipe development,
like how do I go about
doing, creating my recipes?
And one thing I found is that
gluten free baking is actually
still a pretty new field.
And so it's very exciting
and you can be innovative.
And what I really like is
I get to investigate things
and figure out what
is actually going
on with the flours and
the other ingredients.
And how do I mix all
of these together
to create a thing
that I want to eat
and that I want to
share with other people.
What I found that
I like to do is
I like to start
with the classics.
So I like to start with
cookies and bread and cakes
and all of these things.
But I also start with
classic techniques.
So I went back to basic,
good classical baking.
One thing I found over
the course of time
is even if you
adapt the recipes,
so you take your flour
in use it on some recipes
you found in another
book, sometimes
you need to adjust
certain ingredients.
So I found that, for example,
mostly gluten free things
need a leavener, so like baking
soda, baking powder, yeast.
I found that classic
techniques are really helpful.
So for example beating
the fat and the sugar,
so the butter and
the sugar, together
to create the air pockets that
allow the leavener to work.
That works really well
for gluten free baking.
We've kind of forgotten
that as wheat bakers.
Often I have found that my
readers need extra information.
I get a lot of
people who are coming
to baking never
having baked before.
So when I write recipes
I need to make sure
that someone who really doesn't
know the kitchen very well
is able to use
them and bake well.
And then I also have to be
aware of other substitutions.
How many people here are
not only gluten intolerance
but are intolerant
to other things?
Dairy, eggs, nuts.
So, wow, that's unusual.
Usually I get a lot
of folks who are also
intolerant other things.
And so in my book
and my recipes I'm
always trying to give people
different substitutions
for the common things.
So for the dairy and
the eggs in particular.
And then often I try
to make my recipes
so they don't hinge
on nuts, so they
can keep the nuts in
or out if they want to.
OK so I have a blog.
I don't know if anyone goes
to my blog, but on my blog
it's called "Art of Gluten Free
Baking" and I share recipes.
I share baking tips.
I share, I interact
with my readers
and I get feedback from
them about what they want.
I answer questions, and I
also teach folks a little bit
about baking, how to
maneuver this world
called gluten free living.
I try to make it a place
that is helpful and friendly
and that people feel like
they can come to and get
some information from.
And it's been really
satisfying for me.
One thing that I
have in my past is
I have a Ph.D. in
theater history.
And so this really
touches my teaching side.
I haven't been a
professor for a long time,
but it's very helpful
to have this venue
that I can interact
with people and teach.
So I have recipe principles.
I don't know if these are
interesting to people or not.
But one thing I've learned
is that it's important for me
to follow a list of
things that help ground me
when I'm developing recipes.
So I like to learn
from the past.
And one thing I
always keep in mind
is, even though everyone
today, I don't know,
buys puff pastry
from the supermarket,
I can't buy puff pastry.
So I have to make it myself.
And I keep realizing that
a long time ago, there
was no such thing as a
supermarket or the frozen food
section so they had
to make everything.
So whenever something
feels almost
impossible to make I think
no, at one point in history
that was made by human
beings and I can do that.
So there's nothing I found
that I can't mimic, other
than San Francisco sourdough.
I do have a sourdough
recipe on my site
but I don't have San Francisco
sourdough because, as you know,
that needs a particular
yeast, and on and on.
The other thing again I use
classic baking techniques.
I always try to go
back to the basics
if things aren't working out.
I try to think
outside of the box.
This is really important
because sometimes people
get stuck in doing things the
way they've always been done.
So for example, I make a
gluten free potato gnocchi,
you know, the little dumplings,
and they were not behaving well
when I tried to
boil them in water.
And after several
tries I realized,
OK I need to cook these
in a different way.
Now you can pan fry them
and they're delicious
but I still wanted to
do the water cooking.
And I realized that steaming
them worked very well.
So instead of putting them
all the way in the water,
I allowed the water to
come to them to cook them.
So that was very
helpful for me to really
to remember think
outside the box.
Don't do the things you
always did necessarily.
I also call pasta
making humid baking.
I don't know, that's goofy.
But a lot of the same
principles apply to pasta
making as applied to baking.
I'm also opened a new paradigms.
So this it straddles two worlds.
It's in classic baking but
it's also its own thing.
And so you have to be open to
completely new ways of doing
things.
And I found this with bread.
I don't know if any--
has anyone here made
gluten free bread before?
So one thing about
gluten free bread
is that you don't
really knead it
because there's no gluten
to develop in it, right?
And my bread is more like
a very thick cake batter.
Now a lot of people
are getting stuck
on the concept of kneading
their gluten free bread.
But if you can get out
of that and realize
that you don't need
to knead bread,
it's more of a
need to mix bread,
then you have a lot more
you can do with your bread.
And so that's one thing--
that's an example of I
always try to keep things
in perspective in that I
need to not get
stuck in old ways.
And old ways are
good if they work
but if they don't work
you need to move on.
And I always refine my recipes.
I mean I'm not
constantly changing them
but if I find different
methods or different techniques
or even different
ingredients sometimes I
think OK I will refine this
recipe make it even better.
And then my core idea if
it's not delicious then
it's not ready.
I try not to put recipes up
on my site until they're done
and until they're delicious.
And one thing, just
because I lost my ability
to digest gluten, doesn't
mean I lost my ability
to taste things.
And I think a lot
of people forget
that about gluten free people.
So I don't settle.
I want things to be
just as excellent
as they used to be for me.
So I wrote a cookbook here.
Some of you have it.
It's called "Gluten-Free
Baking For The Holidays;
60 Recipes for Traditional
Festive Treats."
Its for the winter holiday
season so Thanksgiving,
Hanukkah, Christmas,
Kwanzaa, and New Year's.
It has recipes but it
also includes baking tips
and it includes ingredient
and equipment info.
So where to find ingredients,
how to choose ingredients,
how to choose equipment
and where to find it.
I really had a lot of
fun writing this book.
Here's the cover.
I was very lucky, I'm
with Chronicle Books
and they do just
beautiful books.
And so I'm just thrilled
with how my book came out.
One thing about
the holiday time is
that it's a time of community
and it's a time of traditions.
And I have found
that one thing gluten
free people need
during the holidays is
to be able to partake
in the traditions
and the festivities
with everybody else.
It's not that nice
to go to Thanksgiving
and be served like your
own little plate that
has a piece of Turkey on it,
may be some steamed green beans,
and to be told,
well everything else
has gluten so that's
your special plate.
I want to be part of it.
I want to have the stuffing,
I want to have the pie,
I want to have the cookies, I
want to have the dinner rolls,
and I want to have them
with everybody else.
I don't want to have my yucky
old dinner roll on the side.
I want everyone to have
delicious dinner rolls.
And so gluten free
people feel this
need to be part of the
community pretty keenly.
And so I found that
as a society we
use food to bring
people together,
so Thanksgiving is a
really clear example,
but yeah just things
like potlucks,
and PTA bake sales, and cocktail
parties, and birthday parties.
We use the food in
all of these things
to bring the people together.
And if you're leaving
members of the community
out you're telling they're
not part of the community.
And it's very important to
me to bring people back in.
Food reflects and
reinforces traditions,
and the holidays are full
of traditions as you know.
So when I was first
diagnosed in 2000 I thought,
well I'll just educate
everyone about what I can eat,
and how to accommodate
me, and then
everyone will be happy
having Thanksgiving
without all the stuff that they
are used to because they'll
include me and every
one will be happy.
And I realized that's not
that great of a strategy
because people want to have
the things they're used
and that are traditional
especially during the holidays.
And so I have altered the
way I approach gluten free
living, and cooking,
and sharing, and baking.
And I just want to make things
that are so good nobody cares.
That includes everybody,
everyone actually wants
these things, they look forward
to them during the year,
and that my friends and family
aren't sitting around thinking,
oh god, we got to share
with Jeanne again.
So that was a guiding
tenet of my book.
So my cookbook, the
theory is every one--
it provides recipes for all
the traditional elements
of the holidays that everyone
likes and everyone wants
and that everyone can now
eat because they're now
gluten free.
Going forward I am still
doing a lot of development.
I'm working on more ideas.
There's a lot of
uncharted territory
to cover with gluten
free baking, which
I think is really interesting.
Again, it's baking
but you've got
to figure it out all over again,
which is fascinating to me.
And I really enjoy
the challenge of it.
I have a lot more to learn.
I think everyone does.
I'm trying to work on
more difficult recipes.
So things like croissants,
artisan breads,
like I said some pastas,
because a lot of pastas
it's hard to make
them at home because
of the cooking limitations.
I'm also trying to learn more
about my own intolerances.
As I get older and finding that
I react not so great to dairy
and not so great to eggs.
I can still eat them,
but I can't eat them
the way I used to.
So I'm trying-- even though
I've always done this,
I am re-upping my
commitment to looking
for excellent substitutions
to give us options.
Not as the only thing but to
give us options in my books
and on my site.
And then I'm always
trying to listen and learn
from my readers, to listen
to them and learn from them.
Because I get so
much information
from my readers
in terms of what's
available out there, what's
not available out there,
what people want,
what people like.
And so that's something
I'm trying to always do.
Where to find me.
You can find me on my blog
"Art of Gluten-Free Baking."
I'm also on Twitter
as "Four Chickens."
My first blog was
"Four Chickens"
because I have chickens
in my backyard,
and it was like a
knitting blog, and nobody
read it, but whatever.
So I switched it over to baking.
I'm also on Facebook as
Art of Gluten free Baking
and then I have my email there.
So you can find me in
many different places.
So what I would like
to do is open it up
for questions from
folks or comments
or ideas whatever you
guys have on your minds.
AUDIENCE: I have an
aunt who has been
diagnosed with celiac disease.
We think we're
trying to figure out
if there's any genetic link to
my sister, who is starting--
has always displayed
symptoms that you mentioned.
I'm wondering do you feel first
that your flour mixture is
good for pizza dough?
That's one thing that we
have yet to find a good one.
JEANNE SAUVAGE: It is.
I have a recipe on my
site for pizza dough
and it's actually
just naturally vegan.
You don't need
dairy or eggs in it,
so it works for a lot of people.
And I've also-- I have
it for the regular baked
in the oven and
also grilled pizza,
so if that's interesting.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
My other question is
kind of along the lines
of the beginning of your talk.
I mentioned my sister's been
displaying some symptoms
and has pretty much cut it out.
And we've learned that in order
to get the official diagnosis,
she actually would have
to reintroduce it and go
through the hell that is
bringing it back into her life.
Do you have any suggestions
for somebody who's facing that?
Is it best to just cut it
out and say what the heck?
Or do you suggest going through
the process to really know?
JEANNE SAUVAGE: If you
don't know, in order
to be diagnosed as
celiac, you need
to-- it's a double
diagnosis process.
You have to test positive
to a blood test, the gliadin
antibodies test,
and then you also
have to have a bowel biopsy.
Because one thing
that the gluten is
doing if you have celiac
is it's flattening
the villi in your
lower intestine.
And that causes people
to not absorb things.
So people who are
celiac are often
anaemic, they have osteoporosis,
they are more inclined
to different cancers, on top of
the fact that they feel gross.
So the question is do you go
through the entire process
and in order to test well,
to do accurately test,
you need to be eating gluten.
Now if you figured out
gluten makes you feel gross,
and you stop eating gluten, and
then a while later someone says
oh would you like
to test for that?
You say yes and they
say, oh by the way
you need to do three weeks
of eating whole wheat bread.
Now for me that
wasn't an option.
So here's the deal.
When I was tested-- and this
may be helpful for your sister--
I tested positive
to the blood tests.
And there are very few
false positives for celiac.
There are a lot of
false negatives,
but there are very
few false negatives.
And then the next
step was I needed
to undergo the bowel biopsy and
I declined the bowel biopsy.
First of all, the test was
positive, that was fine.
But even more important, I
didn't react well to gluten.
I felt horrible
when I ate gluten.
So my answer is it depends on
if your sister will avoid gluten
if a doctor doesn't
tell her to do so.
Does that make sense?
So some people won't
go off of gluten
even though they feel horrible
every single time they eat it.
But they will not
go off gluten often
if they are not given a
diagnosis with these tests.
So do you think your
sister would officially
go off of it if she
didn't have the test?
Then I would say no,
she knows the deal.
You have it, you were
diagnosed with it?
No.
Who was diagnosed?
Nobody was?
AUDIENCE: My aunt.
JEANNE SAUVAGE:
Oh your aunt, OK.
So there is a huge
percentage rise.
So if you have a
close family member
who has been
diagnosed with celiac,
there is some huge percentage
of increased possibility
that you will be diagnosed
with gluten intolerance.
So that's why we always
test our daughter.
Because right now she's not
showing any symptoms of celiac
but you want to be sure
that she never does.
One thing I want to
clarify is I technically,
I guess in some
medical circles, am not
celiac because I didn't
undergo the bowel biopsy,
which is interesting.
So I tell people
most of the time
that I'm gluten intolerance.
But I did test positive
to the blood test
but I declined the
biopsy, which is a thing.
Now on top of it,
I think I shared--
I don't know if I shared with
you-- about four years ago,
I was diagnosed with
a wheat allergy,
and I am anaphylaxis to wheat.
So it doesn't really
matter if I'm celiac
or not because if I
eat wheat I can die.
The last time accidentally ate
it I landed in the hospital
because I was
undergoing anaphylaxis
and I had to get there quickly
in order to be able to breathe.
So that's a long
answer to the thing.
I don't know that
other people, but I
feel like if I feel gross
when I eat something
I don't eat it anymore.
But our society really
isn't built like that.
I know so many
people who continue
to eat the thing that makes
them feel bad because they're so
used to it and they like it.
Or I have a friend
that says, well
gluten makes me
feel bad so I only
eat it on special occasions.
And I think so you
go to the party
and you eat it and
you feel gross?
That doesn't make a
ton of sense to me.
Like for them that's a fun time.
For me, that's not a fun time.
But our society has such
strong connections to food
that have nothing to do with
what it does to our bodies
that people will
do stuff like this.
And this may even sound
familiar to you or the people
in your life.
AUDIENCE: Just another
question about using your mix.
Do you use it for thickening,
like in soups or things
like that?
JEANNE SAUVAGE: I do.
AUDIENCE: Any modifications
you would make to it?
JEANNE SAUVAGE: No, huh-uh.
I use it tablespoon
for tablespoon
and I use it for roux, I
use it for the chenille,
I use it for gravy.
So use it for all
sorts of things.
It seems to work really well
for all of those things.
I make a New Orleans gumbo
and I make the roux first
and it performs beautifully.
It turns that nice chocolate
brown and it's really nice.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Super.
Have you have tried some of
the other baking mixes that
are flour mixes
that are out there
and do anything to compare?
JEANNE SAUVAGE:
You know, I have.
I highly recommend
the King Arthur mix.
I don't know if
anyone's used that one.
That's a nice one.
It's pretty
reasonable, it has many
of the same ingredients
that my mix says.
I'm not sure if it
have xanthan gum
so if it doesn't
have xanthan gum be
sure to add about a
quarter teaspoon per cup
for your regular baking.
Not for yeast breads, that's
a whole different thing,
but for regular baking.
We were talking
earlier about cup
for cup, which is the one that
Thomas Keller has developed.
I think you can buy
it in Williams Sonoma.
And cup for cup I
don't recommend.
First of all I haven't used
it so I can't tell you how
if I like how it works.
But it's got milk
powder in it and so
many people I know who
are gluten intolerant
also don't do that
well with dairy
so I figure why even add
that into the situation.
AUDIENCE: It sounds like you
have a lot of great recipes
that aren't just baking.
Are you going to write another
cookbook with your pizza
and gnocchi and
other great things?
JEANNE SAUVAGE: You
know, I hope to.
That is something
that's in the works.
So yeah, I hope to do that.
And I have all of these
things on my site as well.
So I've got the
pizza on my site,
I've got puff pastry
on my site, I've
got pasta dough on my site.
And I guess the
end, there you go.
But yeah, I have a ton
of stuff on my site
that are-- it's all free.
And I also answer
questions so people often
will write me and say, this
is my family's special recipe
for German coffee cake and would
you be willing to adapt it?
And if I have the
time and I want to I
will do that for folks.
I mean if I become
super duper popular
I don't know how
much I can do that.
But that's part of what
I-- Earlier this year I
wanted to define for myself what
my goal was with all of this.
I mean my first goal,
of course, was for me.
I wanted to be able
to eat these things.
But my second goal
is to serve people,
to help folks be
able to eat again.
And to be able to bake again
and be able to enjoy this again.
And so I wanna
really continue that,
and that's why I try to
be as successful as I
can on social media
and on my site.
Because I really want
to help out folks.
AUDIENCE: More of a
curiosity, I noticed
that in your recipe for the
flour, one of the ingredients
is glutenous rice flour, which
I assume does not have gluten.
JEANNE SAUVAGE: No.
AUDIENCE: But is it just a lot
of starch, or what makes it
glutenous?
JEANNE SAUVAGE: Yeah
it has a lot of starch.
It's also known as sticky rice
flour and the glutenous part,
as you picked up, it
just means it's sticky.
It's called sweet rice
flour most of the time.
You can buy it in
the supermarket
often in the ethics section
in a little white box that's
labeled mochiko.
And it's used a lot
in Asian baking.
But it is confusing.
I get tons of questions
about, you're gluten free
and you use glutenous
rice flour and so I
have to explain that the rice is
not a gluten containing grain.
So it's just a weird
thing, I don't know why.
But it actually is a really
good part of the mix.
In addition to the xanthan gun,
it helps bring things together,
which I think is nice.
Another thing, just
talking about my mix,
I recommend to folks so
you see this in my book
and I have it on my
site but I recommend
that if you are
sensitive to graininess--
this is one of the
issues that often happens
with gluten free
flour, always look
for the finely ground flours.
So like there's extra
fine grind brown rice
flour that you can find.
Now if you can't find it and
you're just using brown rice
flour-- like I use the
flours from Bob's Red Mill,
I use flours from
Authentic Foods.
Authentic Foods has the extra
fine grind but Bob's doesn't.
And if it bothers you
enough you can just
stick it in your blender
or your food processor
and grind it up a little more
and make it a little more fine.
So that works too.
The one I would not recommend
in terms of the mix,
you asked about mix, the Bob's
Red Mill Mix, is not so good.
Do you guys have
Bob's Red Mill here?
Yeah OK.
It has a lot of
bean flour in it.
And it's just very
strong tasting.
And I don't know why
they keep having it.
But when you make things--
so part of when I bake,
like I bake cookies.
I eat some of
cookie dough, that's
just kind of part of what I do.
You cannot do that when
there's a bean flour involved
because it's so strong and
it's so yucky, basically.
That's why I recommend stay
away from the bean flours.
Also the bean flours
are very high in protein
and they go rancid very quickly.
So you need to store those
in the freezer usually.
And I have that in my book
and on my site but something
to keep in mind.
Did that answer your question
about the glutenous rice?
So more questions?
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned you have
people ask you to
adapt lots of recipes.
When you're doing
that adaptation,
what would you say is the most
common change you're making?
JEANNE SAUVAGE: Well
the flour, of course.
The other, probably the two
most common changes I make
is in terms of the leaveners.
So often things don't
have enough leavening.
And when I say leavener, I mean
the thing that makes it rise,
so baking powder,
baking soda, yeast.
So most gluten free recipes I
found need more of those things
often.
Now using classic
baking techniques
actually sometimes
makes it so you
don't have to because
you're creating the air
pockets that the
leaveners can work on.
For example, you beat the
fat and the sugar together.
So it's the leaveners
that I often do.
Sometimes eggs.
I find that there's
not enough eggs
in baking to create
the moisture and also
to create some of the structure.
And then with yeast, you
need to have much more yeast
than you would normally have.
Those are probably the most
common changes that I make.
And the other thing is
gluten free things seem
to take a little bit
longer to cook, to bake.
So I often either increase
the temperature or at least
I increase the time.
And I think part of that
is-- Do you guys know
the concept of hydration?
So in baking parlance
the hydration of a dough
is the percentage of the
water or liquid in a dough.
And I have found that
gluten free things
do well with more liquid
in it, more water,
because they dry out
much more quickly.
And I think that then leads
to a longer baking time
because you need to
bake some of that out.
Is that helpful?
There's one thing
that's hard, is
I try to tell
people, for example
if you have a cookie
recipe and you
want to adapt it, I just
tell people use my mix.
Use the cup for cup for the
wheat flour in your recipe,
see what happens.
And for something like a
cookie that usually suffices.
Then you get a little
more complicated,
you get into muffins and scones.
Sometimes you need tweaks,
sometimes you don't.
Get into cakes, that's
more complicated.
But I always tell people to
try and see what happens.
And then once they
see what happens,
if it's not to their
liking they can kind of
reverse engineer what happened.
So was it too dry?
OK it's too dry, add more
eggs or add more liquid.
Didn't rise.
OK did you beat the eggs,
the fat, and the sugar?
Yes.
OK you need more leavener.
Did it come out kind of
wet after you've baked it?
Yes.
OK you need to raise
baking temperature.
You need to put it in longer.
So I think I ultimately would
like to get to the point
where I can teach people
to do this themselves.
But each recipe seems
to be its own bird.
And so, so far I haven't
been able to say,
for all muffins you need to
make this adaptation, that kind
of thing.
So that's what makes
it complicated.
But I tell people to try
and see what happens.
But one thing you can't
adapt cup for cup at all
is a yeasted recipe.
Yeasted recipes are
their whole other bird.
You need more yeast,
you need more liquid,
often you need more
eggs, you need more time.
And so when people tried
to do, for example,
they try to do their
moms bread with my flour
mixture it doesn't work so well.
Because there's so many
different variables
that go into a yeasted thing.
So that's a challenge.
Although like I said
I do have a sourdough
on my site, which is fun because
you develop your own sourdough
starter.
And then from there
you make the bread
which is a fun-- if you
like that kind of thing--
it's a fun process.
And I harvest the wild yeast.
I don't use commercial
yeast, I harvest wild yeast
and I show you how to do that.
So that's kind of fun.
AUDIENCE: So a lot of
the gluten free baking
I do is for somebody who
is also rice intolerant
and I encounter that a lot
in the recipes in your--
JEANNE SAUVAGE: Right.
AUDIENCE: --mix.
So any suggestions
for direction to go
if rice flour is not
really an option?
JEANNE SAUVAGE: Yes.
In my book, if you've
got the book I've got,
some substitutions--
like for, with for the--
so I don't think I can
remember all of them.
I have it on my site but I
think it's for the-- now this
will alter my mix and
things will behave and taste
a little different.
But for the brown
rice flour it'll
tell you substitute sorghum.
For the white rice flour, tell
you just substitute millet
flour.
For the sweet rice flour, I tell
you to substitute potato flour.
For the tapioca flour you
substitute potato starch,
two different things.
And then you use
the xanthan gum.
So you're going to have
a different tasting mix,
it's going to be a little
more flavorful because millet
and sorghum taste has a taste.
Also you may want to
grind the sorghum cause
sorghum tends to
be kinda gritty.
And the millet too,
kind of depends.
Also be aware that the starch
is weirdly enough-- even
tapioca starch will go bad-- way
quicker than you think they do.
And I don't really
understand why.
A lot of people tell me they
don't like tapioca starch.
Now the weird thing, tapioca
starch and tapioca flour,
same thing.
Potato starch and potato
flour, not the same thing.
So it's really complicated.
But what I found
is starches tend
to go very rancid very quickly.
And people would tell me they
don't like tapioca flour often
its they don't like
rancid tapioca flour.
If it tastes metallic and
disgusting, it's gone bad.
I think what I want to tell
you is if the potato starch is
tasting funky, then
to switch that out.
So any of these flours, if
you're not using them quickly,
I recommend you store
them in the fridge
or you store them
in the freezer just
to make your not running
into the going bad thing.
I had a fabulous photographer
and she made things-- well they
look like this--
but she also just
brought out how good they taste.
So I am quite lucky to have her.
I really enjoyed the whole
process of writing this book.
It was fun and delicious.
I spend most of 2011
in Christmas land,
which is not a bad
place to be really.
One thing I have in my book,
just as a little teaser,
I've got fortune
cookies in the book.
So if you're gluten
free and you haven't
had a fortune cookie
in a long time,
you can have fortune cookies.
That's always fun.
I have fruitcake, plum pudding,
pies, dinner rolls, cookies.
So thank you very
much for having me.
It's been an honor and
it's been a lot of fun.
I appreciate it.